-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated writer
and comedian who is the
longest-serving "Weekend Update"
anchor in the history
of "Saturday Night Live,"
which returns this week
with host Adam Driver
and musical guest
Olivia Rodrigo.
His new scripted podcast,
"Trust Fall,"
a photo he was not
in the room...
[ Laughter ]
Like, how would that happen?
Just be honest.
[ Laughter ]
"Trust Fall" is available
on Audible.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend Colin Jost!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
Thank you.
-You know, they're applauding me
for having the courage
to call you out.
-Yeah.
What -- What looks fake?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Have you ever seen
me and Wanda together,
and we didn't look like this?
-Yeah, that's true.
You're almost always leaning.
She's taking a good selfie.
I say, now that I see you in
person, you do look like that.
-See?
-Um, uh, It's great.
-It's not far off.
-I see you, uh -- It's my --
-You work -- We work together.
-We work together.
-We were in the same building.
How do you get to work?
-How do I get to work?
The, uh, show, uh, sends a car.
I take a car to work.
How do you get to work?
-Uh, I bike.
I guess I'm just maybe
a little more man of the people.
[ Laughter ]
-You bike.
-I bike, I bike.
-What do you do, a Citi Bike?
-No, I buy bikes.
And then I just throw them away
when I get here.
[ Laughter ]
So I just, you know...
-Yes, man of the people.
-Yeah.
-You just, like,
leave them on the street?
Because there's not, like,
a bike trash can.
-Yeah, well, I mean --
I, well, you know,
it's a Citi Bike-like system.
-But it's just not Citi Bike.
-But I just -- yeah,
but I just throw them away.
And I don't, you know --
I mean, it's --
I don't leave them in a shape
where they could be reused.
[ Laughter ]
You know that big giant pile
of broken bikes
that's right outside?
-That's your bike?
-That's my bikes.
Haven't you ever wondered?
You thought it was one of those
cool sculptures they put up
sometimes at 30 Rock.
-I did. I thought it was Koons.
-Oh, I get Koons a lot.
[ Laughter ]
-That's great. That's your
favorite kind of bike?
The one you just do once?
-Yeah.
The disposable bikes.
-I think I'm
an environmental guy, you know.
You guys know that about me.
But I bike my bike.
And I don't know
if you've noticed now --
I feel like,
in the last year --
maybe you guys
have noticed this, too --
that somehow
they've allowed pedicabs
to just blast the loudest music
you've ever heard.
[ Laughter ]
And for some reason,
I find that they're all
exclusively playing "Despacito."
-Yeah.
-Like, it's like
it's a very festive version
of hell, you know?
Like, that's all you hear.
And it's so loud,
and I will just be biking,
I'm like,
"Oh, what's approaching me
from behind?
Is it the entire
Puerto Rican Day parade?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's a single
empty pedicab.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I realized that all
the speakers project out.
So if you're in
the actual pedicab,
it's relatively quiet.
-Yeah.
You're, like, you think
you're on your way
to a club 20 blocks away
that's playing "Despacito."
-Exactly. I mean, the dream.
-The dream.
-We all, you know...
-You're like, "Faster!"
-Yeah.
-Do you ever, in those moments,
like, when you see
an empty pedicab blasting music,
do you try to step in and go,
like, "I might --"
again, this isn't
my business per se,
but I might have a note,
"I feel like, by blasting this,
people don't want to be
in your pedicab."
-Maybe -- I think it's aimed
at, like, a full family,
that the dad is so upset
at everyone
and he's like,
"Just get in the --
I don't want to hear
any of you anymore.
I just need 'Despacito'
right now."
[ Laughter ]
I think that's
what "Despacito" means --
"Desperate Dad."
-They say, "'Despacito' times
call for 'Despacito' measures."
-That's right, that's right.
You know.
-We know this famous saying.
-Famously.
-You're back in the swing
at the show.
It's been lovely
to have you guys back.
We missed a few
because of the writers' strike.
And now it's been wonderful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's great.
It's been very nice.
-Love the new cast.
Love the young cast.
-I love the new cast.
They're great.
The last couple years
have been really great.
They're all fun.
I love hanging out with them.
They're doing great on the show.
And it's very nice to be back.
We got Adam Driver
who's, like, fantastic.
Really, really very good
at the show.
-I'm happy about the outcome
for the real person,
but Bowen as George Santos
was a real gift to the show.
-That was so --
and to all of America, really.
-All of America.
And you know,
maybe not the most obvious
casting in the beginning,
but you guys worked
on this together.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he -- You know,
Bowen is fantastic.
And I feel like I don't think
it's necessarily goodbye
to George Santos.
I feel like it's, "Hello,
a thousand documentaries
about him," is my guess.
I feel like
we'll probably see him.
Like, there's almost no chance
he's not
in a Super Bowl commercial
for, like, pistachios.
-Yeah,
and someone's like, "George!"
That definitely is a line.
-And he's like, "What?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Pistachios.
-I'm Mr. Pistachio.
-[ Chuckles ]
And then he also, like --
I do feel like
what I thought about
George Santos, too,
is that almost, like, we should
give him more credit
because he was able
to get elected,
but he only -- he used all
the campaign stuff on,
like, Botox and, you know,
like Hermès.
Like, these other people
spent it all on the campaign
and couldn't win.
-Yeah.
-Isn't that kind of impressive?
-Well, of course you won.
You con those people
out of their money,
and you used it
to run against us.
He's like, "No."
-"No."
Would you have rather --
wouldn't you rather him
look like real, like,
you know, sauced up
instead of having to see, like,
another campaign ad from him?
It's cool, you know?
-It is very -- Again,
the best thing about him is
the lies didn't seem impressive.
Like, he lied about things
that you wouldn't think
another person would vote
for you if you were like,
"Oh, he played
college volleyball.
He's my guy."
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I never thought
I would try --
that someone would try
to impress me
with college volleyball.
-And Santos did, and it worked.
-And that's
why he's a visionary.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He also does make --
I feel like he made people
feel better
about themselves, too.
Like, you know,
when you saw that going on,
you're like, "Oh,
I'm not that bad of a person."
[ Laughter ]
-Adam Driver
was in "Marriage Story"
with your wife,
Scarlett Johansson.
-That's right.
-Is that a weird thing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it up for "Marriage Story."
-Yeah, great movie.
-Because that was, like,
maybe one of the best movies
ever made
about the dissolution
of a marriage.
-Yes, I guess it is --
It's odd to meet someone
who played a person
who divorced your wife.
That's a weird -- 'Cause I guess
when you date an actor,
I've heard, you know,
they sometimes
have to kiss people in movies
or whatever.
-You found out, though,
after you said "I do," right?
-The minute after.
-Yeah.
She's like,
"Now that it's official,
I have some things
to tell you about acting."
-She's like,
"Look at this list!"
I'm kidding.
I don't keep a list.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Uh, yeah, it is weird to meet
someone that that was played --
because you're like, "Oh, I was
in a movie with your wife."
"Oh, what did you do?"
"I divorced her."
And by the way, I should have
said "spoiler alert,"
but "Marriage Story" is
actually about divorce.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So if you thought like, "Oh,
it's a 'Father of the Bride'..."
-You kind of know right away.
-Yeah, right.
They get that out really fast.
-Yeah.
Like, pretty much, like --
-The first line is,
"What are you doing?!
I hate you!"
-Um, we saw each other
at, uh,
the Natural History Museum gala.
-Oh, yes.
Seth emceed the gala
and was fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Great job. Excellent work.
-You sort of went --
You sort of went viral
for a red-carpet moment.
-Did I? Oh, wow.
-I want to show it first.
And then I want you
to explain what happened.
-Okay, okay.
Here's a...
[ Indistinct conversations ]
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
[ Indistinct conversations
continue ]
[ Laughter ]
-So, what happened?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I don't understand.
Are you implying
that someone gave me
some sort of gummy mushroom
right before
I went to the red carpet?
Is that what you're implying?
-And that you froze like a deer
in oncoming traffic,
to the degree that your wife
had to lean over
in front of a camera crew
and be like, "Are you okay?"
[ Laughter ]
-Are you implying that
when a thousand flashbulbs
went off in front of my face,
that I thought I was staring
into the dawn of the cosmos...
[ Laughter ]
...and that I saw,
fully realized, my entire past
and future in one moment,
until my wife had to rip me
out of the space-time continuum
and say, "Are you okay?"
[ Laughter ]
I don't know
what you're implying, but...
-Can I tell you something?
-Yeah.
-But I've seen that face before.
-Right.
-Because we work together,
and I want to show it
one more time
and let everybody here know
this is the face Colin
would make if I'd be like,
"Hey, did you finish
writing the cold open?"
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Applause ]
-We'll be right back
with more Colin after this!